you
so I don't know how many people here use
Spotify alright and of those who do use
spot if I don't know how from how
familiar you are we've discovered weekly
but discover weekly is this new feature
that we just launched a few months ago
that's basically a playlist of
recommended personalized music for you
and it's had a lot of great feedback and
it's been in the press a lot lately so
we wanted to talk a little bit about
discover weekly where the idea came from
how we executed on it and we have a
bunch of lessons in building
recommendation products that hopefully
everyone here can learn from so just to
introduce ourselves my name is Chris
Johnson I manage a team of machine
learning engineers here at Spotify I've
been here for about three and a half
years originally worked on the radio
feature at Spotify was the first sort of
recommendation feature we had can start
an artist radio station seeded from an
artist or a song or a playlist just like
you can do with Pandora from there we
built things like related artists then
in 2013 we launched the discover page
which is the sort of personalized page
for you to get all sorts of
recommendations and now 2015 we just
read release discover weekly so that's
the latest thing we've been working on
and do you want to sure in hi hello oh
hi I'm Edward and yeah I joined the team
probably two and a half years ago around
the time we were launching discover cool
so really quickly here's basically
Spotify in numbers so if you're not
familiar with Spotify we started in 2006
we're streaming music platform on-demand
streaming so you can log into Spotify
find anything you want play it create
your own playlists get recommendations
that sort of a thing we're now available
in 58 markets we have 75 plus million
active users when I say active I mean
monthly active twenty million of which
are paying so you've got a pretty good
conversion funnel we've got about 30
million songs on Spotify 20,000 of which
are added every day we've got about one
and a half billion user generated
playlists about a terabyte of user data
gets logged every day and we process all
of this data in our 1,700 node Hadoop
cluster in our data set
we run about ten thousand-plus Hadoop
jobs every day so here's the challenge
we've got 30 million songs on Spotify so
how do we help users sift through all
this music and find great
recommendations so here's some of the
different features we've launched on
Spotify this was the discover page I was
mentioning we launched this in 2013 and
it's changed a little bit since then but
basically you can log in and get a
personalized feed of recommendations for
you so you can see here there's some
strips there's a top recommendations for
you strip new releases for you and then
we have strips similar to how Netflix
does it suggested for you based on
something else you listen to radio is
another feature we have that you can get
recommendations on so here I started a
radio station from Sonic Youth and will
play music similar to that and you can
give it feedback so you can give it a
thumbs up or a thumbs down and it'll
start tuning to your taste another place
you can get recommendations is through
related artists so if you have an artist
you really like and you're looking for
our other artists that are similar to
that artists you can go to the artists
page and find other similar so here I've
gone to the Fleet Foxes artist page and
you can see there's a bunch of artists
that are related to Fleet Foxes so you
can imagine going down this rabbit hole
of continually clicking through related
artists and going through this music
wormhole and finally this year in 2015
we just released discover weekly so this
is mainly what we're gonna focus on in
this talk and it's this great
personalized playlist of music for you
so every week every Monday you wake up
you know you're kind of sad it's like
all the weekends over I have to go to
work now but things are better now
mondays are a little bit better you can
wake up and start your day with some
fresh music recommendations so it's a
personalized playlist of music like I
said it's available on all platforms and
every Monday it's going to update with
about two hours or thirty songs of new
music for you and it's been getting
quite a bit of press so we just reached
within 10 weeks we reached 1 billion
track stream from discover weekly
is a really cool milestone for us and
I'm gonna let Edward take over and talk
a little bit how we got there cool yeah
so just as Chris mentioned this has
probably been maybe the most successful
launch we've had at Spotify so just next
for a little bit I'd like to talk about
how we got there so as Chris mentioned
and Pete probably about two and a half
three years ago is when we launched our
first personalized feature at Spotify
the discover page and it was a newsfeed
kind of layout and kind of like a
Pinterest layout of a bunch of different
types of content that were
recommendations or personalized in some
way so we had stuff like recommended
artists for you new releases reviews
like concerts in your area even stuff
like playlists recommend it based on
what people are listening to in your
social network and so it was cool
because it was like this one place you
could go and you could pretty much find
whatever music content you wanted one
thing about it is that it required a ton
of attention and interaction in order to
find what you're looking for so you you
know we figured users just scroll
through the page until they found okay I
was looking for this type of music or
whatever let's check this out
yeah so there was no real organization
of content other than we tried to
enforce that the content types that were
different would be kind of placed near
each other so there wouldn't be too many
like new releases next to each other
things like that so we iterated on it a
bit and then in 2013 in the last year
there was a major UX overhaul of the
entire client and that's when we came
across this Netflix style layout which
we introduced across the other features
like the Browse genres etcetera features
and Spotify and for discover what we did
is we just stripped away most of those
content types and focused on simplifying
it to just being albums that we could
recommend to you and new releases so
like Chris mentioned there's suggested
for you based on something you listen to
and then there's also strips around new
releases for you or just like top
recommendations based on what you've
been listening to lately so it was more
organized so it's easier to navigate and
figure out you know if like you're into
a certain style right now you could
probably find that easier but it still
required a lot of interaction you would
to come in every time you wanted to
listen to a new album rien you know
interact with the page again once you
know the album finished you would have
to come back to the page like there was
nothing that kept it continuously
streaming or whatever so we compared
this then to the Browse feature that we
had just launched and browse was the new
homepage for Spotify when you first log
in and it shows you just a list of
playlists that are hand curated by our
internal editorial team and it was stuff
like your favorite coffee house or
something that kind of captured a mood
or a style and what was nice is that
it's usually like something like four
hours long so once you've found the
style you're into like study music I'm
beyond electro or something like that
you just put it on and then you could go
about your day doing whatever else you
were doing so what we get from this is
that users are spending a lot more time
in browse than they are in discover and
you know maybe it just has something to
do with the the experience there so an
initial idea out of that is maybe we can
combine the personalized experience of
discover with the Leanback ease of the
Browse page another insight then is that
around that time and at the end of last
year we iterated in our second year in
music feature and so this was a separate
web app that we sent emails out about
where if you had an account you could
just log into it and it would show you a
breakdown of your listening history from
2014 so you know it would be breakdowns
of the styles you listen to what your
top artists were that you listen to like
what days of the week you you stream the
most things like that and at the very
bottom of this webpage we introduced
this new feature called play it forward
and what this was is that it was like an
opt-in playlist pretty much you could
press the create button and it would
return a new playlist into your I guess
your list of playlists in the desktop
client and it would just be stuff that's
personalized to you that you haven't
listened to before but based on what you
listened to in 2014 we think you'll like
and so what this was based on is pretty
much everything that powered discover so
the same machine learning models the
same data pipelines everything it
really require much effort for our team
to do this but we took we found out was
that this was actually a huge like
success we looked at our metrics we saw
there were like over five million unique
sessions almost four million unique
users use this feature and what was even
more surprising is that over a month
after the launch there was still
something like 10% of what peak traffic
was was still engaging with this page
and with that playlist so that kind of
gave us you know a new idea like maybe
another discovery product that'd be cool
is like to take this play it forward
idea but to have it more regularly
updated so more regularly updated
discovery kind of playlist and so next
step I'll give to Chris around how we
could be data-driven from start to
finish to building something like this
yes I think that kind of takes us to our
first lesson here remember we're gonna
have four lessons it's actually five
lessons I didn't want at the end but
yeah so this brings us to our first
lesson which is really I think super
important for building recommendation
products and is to be data-driven from
start to finish so what do I mean by
that well there is this really great
blog post from Dan McKinley at formerly
at Etsy's now it's stripe but he's
talking about Etsy's process and how it
used to be and how it is now I thought
it fit pretty nicely and to Spotify
actually so I'm gonna talk a little bit
about sort of the wrong way to do things
and the right way to do things so in
2008 Spotify had just launched and I
think this is more like what the process
was you know you come up with some idea
for some new thing you spend you know X
number of months building it and then
you release it and that's it it's sort
of the old school way of doing things
right the problem with this is you know
you get no feedback you get no
refinement and you're not learning
anything
so by 2013 we were getting a little
smarter about this AV testing was a
pretty regular thing at Spotify by this
time we basically a/b tested everything
any new feature any new content test we
would a/b test it so the process was
more like this you know you come up with
an idea you spend some time coding it
and then
you know you lady test this so let's say
you come up with a new idea for a start
page you'll spend X number of months
coding it up and then you'll a be tested
against your current start page maybe it
succeeds maybe it fails and based on
your a B test results you'll release or
not release the problem with this is you
know you've still got this long cycle of
where you're you know spending four to
six months building this thing and
you're not getting any feedback you're
not refining so to me this really isn't
being data-driven sure at the end you
know you you're leasing an a/b test and
you're deciding whether or not to
release in based on your data but it's
not david driven from start to finish so
this is really again i think the wrong
process so by 2015 and with discover
weekly I think we've kind of gotten in a
pretty good groove of how this should
actually work so we discovered weekly it
was more like this you know we had this
idea we had these insights and we
validated them quickly so things like
the play at forward playlist where it
was very little friction we didn't need
to scale it up to to all of our users it
was an opt-in sort of thing it's an easy
way to sort of validate a hypothesis and
we did and we saw a great engagement
from that playlist so from that you know
the next step would be to prototype
something and you know get some more
further feedback maybe running even a
small a/b test but again not scaling
something up to all your users at first
and so there's this process of sort of
you know validating your hypothesis
prototyping testing with small number of
users refining your process and then
eventually running your a/b test scaling
up and releasing so this is more of the
process that I think we're starting to
follow and I encourage more
organizations to follow so how do you go
about doing this well here's here's a
here's a super important thing to do and
it's to define your success metrics
before you release your tests so I see
this a lot at companies is you know
you'll sort of you'll you'll list out
these ten things that you care about you
know maybe ten metrics or something you
know you care about da you you care
about time spent you clear about you
care about CTR or something like that
you just list out these things and then
you know you'll run your a/b test and
then you'll see you know some things
increase and some things decrease maybe
this feature is great for your existing
users but it really sucks
for new users and then you try to decide
what do I so what do I do now and you
kind of make the data work for you
you're like well it's it's good for
existing users it's okay that it's not
so good for new users I think this is a
win and this is wrong for a lot of
reasons so I think one thing that's
really important is you should define
your success metrics before you release
your test and that way you know you're
not making them you're not sort of
interpreting the data how you want your
at you're sort of making your insights
based on the data that you have so so
that's super important and one thing I
always like to talk about is it's kind
of I think you know for the most part
you can kind of define what you're
trying to do into these sort of three
buckets or these three classes reached
up and retention and so what do I mean
by this
so Reach is like how many users are you
reaching so we discovered weekly the the
reach would be how many users can we
reach would discover weekly the depth is
for the users you do reach what is their
depth of reach okay so not only how many
users are we reaching when we're
reaching them are we reaching them for
you know they just come in every Monday
and stream for ten minutes and then
leave or are they coming back in and
spending hours every day that'd be very
different case right and then retention
is for the users that we do reach how
many of them do we retain so our users
coming in loving discover weekly the
first week and then it gets stale week
after week and so they start dropping
out that's a bad thing we want to try to
retain our users so for its cover weekly
these were the key success metrics that
we defined before we released our test
so we said we really care about reach so
we care about how many how many users
are coming in and using discover weekly
every week so of all the users coming in
to Spotify what percent of them come in
and use discover weekly in a given week
a depth is for the users that we are
reaching how much time are they spending
and discovered weekly are they spending
ten minutes are they spending five hours
and then the last thing is retention so
a week over week how many users are we
retaining so going back to this model
this is the point where we were at a
prototype so we've already validated our
hypothesis with the play it forward
playlist as part of the yeren music so
now we're at that point where we wanted
to actually Pro
type something so often our first step
when we're prototyping is an employee
test so you know it might be kind of
obvious but a great place to gather
feedback when you're prototyping is your
organization itself so Spotify you know
we've got you know around 1,700
employees so this is a great place to
gather feedback around how how something
was working especially a recommendation
product so the first thing we did was we
generated a bunch of playlists for our
employees again it's pretty easy because
we don't have to scale up right we don't
have to generate these for 75 million
users we should have to generate them
for 2,000 or so employees so it's pretty
easy so not scaling up just generating
something for employees and basically we
took this playlist and we just sort of
sneakily forced it and everyone's route
list so we didn't tell people we were
doing this all of a sudden people log in
to Spotify employees and they would just
see this discover weekly playlist there
we want to see like you know are people
gonna notice this are they going to
start questioning it and I think we
mentioned yeah we mentioned in the
description of the playlist we said you
know hey if you've happened to find this
by the way it's an employee only test
but send us an email if you have any
feedback I think in like the first week
people started discovering this we
started getting tons of email and it
kind of became this this sort of viral
thing internally where like people were
you know sort of started discovering it
telling their friends in the office like
hey if you found this discovered weekly
thing like who's this lambda squad I've
never heard of them so it was kind of
cool it was like this sort of like viral
marketing but within the company so we
actually tracked the employee test which
is kind of funny right we actually built
dashboards and tracked how we were
performing with our employees so you can
see here this is our these are our reach
reach depth and retention metrics and we
started tracking them for employees and
we saw a pretty cool thing as you can
see here like people start discovering
the playlist you know our week I use
like 20% of employees or something and
then all of a sudden like it starts
going viral and all of a sudden almost
half of all employees are using this
thing every week and you know what's the
retention like well it's like 80 percent
or something so it was huge the
employees that found this thing they
would come back to it every week so
really cool so at this point we decided
okay this thing this thing's pretty good
we're getting tons of feedback we're
refining our process a bit as we get
getting feedback from our employees and
we decided it's about time to run an a/b
test with actual users so when we get to
this point again we're not gonna scale
up to all users we're just gonna roll
something out to 1% and we got a little
creative here so we started to realize
that you know we can really reach users
on a personal level here so we started
thinking about initially you know we
just had this this generic astronaut man
as our image for the playlist and then
our designers started getting creative
and thinking hey maybe we can actually
you know make this feel really personal
we can start bringing in user images and
things like that so we actually launched
to test out two users one that just had
the generic astronaut and one that
actually had a personalized image and
then we got even trickier we threw in
this link to a Google Form so we this
was kind of like a beta test and again
we just took it and just shoved it into
1% of users route lists so we didn't
tell users this was coming there was no
onboarding process it was just users
would log in and then maybe they'd
noticed that there's this discovered
weekly playlist there and you know using
the description we were able to get a
Google Form in there so that users could
give us actual qualitative feedback
pretty cool we had a lot of responses in
this Google Form for the 1% test so we
got within a few weeks I think we had
like yeah I guess you know a little over
1,200 responses and they were generally
very positive so you can see here we
gave users the ability to rate it on a
one to five scale and like 65% we're
like hey this is like five stars this is
amazing we got tons of feedback users
were giving us comments and you know we
used all these insights to decide you
know how do we want to scale this thing
up what worked about it what didn't work
about it how do we refine it and so
again going back to that data driven
from start to finish it's very important
to kind of you know gather data and
feedback very very early on before you
scale up so another thing that we
learned early on
is the personalized image actually had a
lift of 10% in week 8 you so this was
actually pretty surprising to us we
didn't you know we didn't really think
that we'd see any difference in the
metrics but it turned out that actually
made a huge difference so when we were
doing this when we're thinking about it
it was like okay if we're gonna actually
do this at scale these images these
personalized images for 75 million users
it's going to take quite a bit of
infrastructure that we don't currently
have so this really informed us on hey
this is actually worth it we're gonna
get this 10% lift if we actually do this
so that brings us to our second lesson
which is to reuse existing
infrastructure in creative ways so that
one of the coolest things about discover
weekly is that you know we basically are
just reusing stuff we already had the
algorithms were the same algorithms
we're using for the discover page the
same algorithms we're using for radio
the actual UI and format we were just
reusing the playlist system we already
had this great amazing playlist system
at Spotify and we're just reusing it and
then also I want to encourage you to
kind of think of creative ways in which
you can reuse your infrastructure so
things like you know we reuse the
description in order to put this Google
Form and to get feedback from our users
we're using the image as a way as sort
of a vessel to kind of communicate with
your users and make this thing feel
really personalized so the actual work
that when in discover Weekly was
actually very little about because we're
reusing things that we already had so
here is more or less than discover
weekly data flow and I've kind of
included our data flow for other
features on here so you can kind of see
that discover weekly it was really very
little extra work so this is kind of the
flow at Spotify you know you over here
on the Left you've got the clients or
users they come in they'll hit an access
point we have data centers in Stockholm
London Ashburn Virginia and San Jose
City California
so you'll hit an access point and then
you'll go and you'll try to stream from
a feature maybe a stream from an artist
page a playlist maybe you go to the
discover page all of our streaming data
gets a pass through Kafka I distributed
message-passing framework and we have
hourly jobs that will then basically
listen to Kafka and propagate all of
that into Hadoop distributed file system
so everything goes into HDFS and we run
a lot of Hadoop and scalding jobs
scalding is this great framework based
on top of cascading it's a higher-order
framework for running Hadoop jobs and
you can write all your jobs functionally
in Scala it's really nice so we'll run a
bunch of scalding jobs train some
recommendation models you know so we
have some batch collaborative filtering
models some NLP models on you know track
data or news and blogs and that sort of
a thing we also analyze our raw audio
and train some models on that all this
went into a recommendation pipeline that
was already powering the discover page
so really all we needed to do here was
just also pump out these playlists for
discover weekly and then find a way in
order to publish them and as long as we
could do that we could scale up discover
weekly to all of our users so really
reusing infrastructure was a huge was a
huge win for us so we talked really
briefly about recommendation models and
I'm going to hand it back over to Ed to
talk about the publishing so we use a
ton of recommendation models at Spotify
and we're continually trying to improve
upon them so I just wanted to very
briefly give an outline of the kinds of
things we're looking at so kind of the
lifeblood I think of recommendation
models at Spotify is generally
collaborative filtering and when we're
talking about collaborative filtering at
Spotify we're generally talking about
implicit feedback collaborative
filtering so one thing we do a ton of is
Layton factor models using our implicit
feedback data so we have a lot of data
on what users are streaming and it's
implicit feedback right because just
because you listen to something doesn't
necessarily mean you're saying I
explicitly like this thing if you listen
to Michael Jackson three times I mean
you really love Michael Jackson or we
just kind of passing through go
something one time maybe that's even a
negative signal right so this is kind of
the framework for how you can do an
implicit matrix factorization basically
you aggregate all of your user and track
streams into a big matrix and make it a
big binary matrix so place a 1 anywhere
that a user stream something in a 0
everywhere else and then the goal is
that you're going to approximate a
binary preference with this binary
preference made sure by the product of
two smaller dimensional matrices what
we're gonna do and how are we gonna do
that
well we're gonna solve a weighted least
squares and we're gonna weight based on
the number of times you streamed so if
you streamed Daft Punk 1000 times in my
Jackson once we're going to place more
weight on the Daft Punk positive signal
and so that's what this if you're pretty
familiar with least squares I mean
that's a sense what we're doing here and
then you've got this cui term that's the
confidence that's how much we're going
to weight our individual entries so I
know this is a little bit hand wavy and
quick but come find me later if you're
interested in this sort of thing another
cool thing is you can actually replace
the least-squares loss with the logistic
loss really simple with the same exact
sort of setup except now instead of
using a least-squares loss we're using a
logistic loss and I think this kind of
makes a little more sense for binary
data because least squares doesn't make
it doesn't make a whole lot of sense I
think to say hey we're looking at the
difference between you know a 1 or a 0
and your predicted rating it doesn't
make much sense when when it's binary
data like that so I think logistic loss
actually works a little bit better here
so this is essentially the same setup
except now we're just using a logistic
loss and I have a paper on this that you
can find online called logistic matrix
factorization for implicit feedback data
if you're interested the next thing we
look at we see we run a lot of NLP
models natural language processing
models on news and blogs so we scraped
the web to see what the web is saying
about artists and what kind of
vocabulary they using so you can imagine
you know users that are blogs that are
talking about Kanye West might be using
the same vocabulary as say jay-z or
something like that and so you can sort
of deduce that there's this similarity
between artists just looking at news and
blogs and natural language text so
that's something we do a ton of turns
out that NLP models work really really
well on playlists so this is something
that Eric who you you heard talk
yesterday discovered really early on is
that we've got this treasure trove of
one and a half billion playlists that
it's an amazing data set because you can
think of them it's just a bunch of
documents and then you can think of all
the tracks inside the playlists as just
words and so now we've got all of these
documents with words they're cleverly
placed together such that the ones that
are close to each other are similar in
some way and when you've got one and a
half bill
of them you've got so much data that
you're gonna find these very sort of
niche similarities and so we do a ton of
analysis on playlists and actually I
think this is you know if not the most
important piece of data we have for
discover weekly because if you think
about it we're trying to build a
personalized playlist of music and we're
training on one and a half billion
playlists that other users have created
and so we're learning how do you create
a playlist we've got tons of data on
that so we can actually train algorithms
to understand how you create a really
great amazing playlist the last sort of
area that I'll mention here is we also
look at our underlying audio content and
try to Train layton factor models on
that so a couple summers ago guys Sandra
Dielman from Ghent University he's now
at google deepmind he came and did an
internship with us and he had this
really great paper on how you can train
convolutional neural network models on
the raw audio data this is a audio
spectrogram here you can think of it as
a time frequency data and basically you
train some convolutions with some max
pooling at the end of all of this you're
trying to predict latent factor models
that we've been trained using
collaborative filtering so now you know
you can train this model you have a new
song come in even if you don't have any
user data on it it's not been added to
any playlist you can actually run the
raw audio through this model and get out
a latent factor vector that actually
kind of makes sense this is another area
we look at so I mentioned leighton
factor models a bunch but really what am
I talking about when I say that so if
you never seen this before
essentially all the models that we're
training they're placing all of our
songs on Spotify in this high
dimensional space so think of it like a
40 dimensional or a hundred dimensional
space such that the items that are very
similar to each other are going to be
close in that space defined by some
metric in our case it's generally the
cosine distance so here if you
normalized all the tracks the cosine
distance between them is essentially the
similarity between the trucks so how
many people recognize all four of these
album covers yeah that's awesome one
person okay sorry I did
another at another conference and like
nobody knew it so I'm really happy we
got at least somebody anyways you're
super cool so yeah so essentially you
know we put all the songs in this space
and we also put users in the same space
right and so then what you can do is you
can just look at any user in this space
and you can look at the cosine distance
to all the songs and the ones that have
the that are the closest are going to be
essentially the greatest recommendations
for you so that's basically
recommendation models I'm going to hand
it back over to Ed and he's going to
talk about how we scale up yeah so
getting back to discovery weekly then so
yeah we've discovered from our a/b
testing our user tests that this is
great now we have to worry about the
hard part scaling it up to 100% of our
users so this actually did turn out to
be the most expensive part of the
project and it had to do with
interacting between three different
offices Gothenburg in Sweden is the
office where our team that handles the
play listing system operates out of
there's also an office in Stockholm
that handles some other of the you know
the systems involved so the major
challenge then is how do we create and
publish 75 million playlists in a timely
manner we wanted to do it all within a
week and that was to align with an
internal press announcement around it we
didn't want to announce hey there's this
cool new feature and then like have most
users go to check for it and can't find
it so we gave that constraint and then
additionally the constrain around the
personalized images since we saw such a
huge lift in engagement for users that
had their image personalized to their
Facebook image we decided that right out
of the gate we should try our best to
have that as the initial feature so we
had to interact with the Facebook API do
a lot of image processing and also
upload this to a different service then
of course Spotify is an international
product so we'd have to worry about
translating not only the description of
the playlist but also the image where it
says discover weekly into what would be
relevant like 20 plus different
languages another end of it then is the
weekly refresh so we've constrained
ourselves to say hey everybody this is
going to be available for you on Monday
mornings
so it's the first time I think with
Spotify we've had a really
time-sensitive update to worry about and
you know with that came a lot of other
things like we have to worry about time
zones for instance somebody in Australia
would need to see this I think it's
probably going to be refreshed in the
next couple hours from for Monday
morning whereas in the in Europe or the
u.s. it's gonna be later in the day so
how do we refresh 75 million play us
every Sunday night so just a quick
overview overview of the publishing
workflow here's what we ended up with
and this was the quickest way to get
this out so we start with our discover
weekly recommendations which are you
know based on Hadoop jobs so they live
in HDFS and we have a publisher that
uses rabbitmq to paralyze the publishing
so there's two major things that's doing
one is that each of these workers is
going to for each playlist check with
Facebook to see if the user is connected
but also if their image has changed and
if so we'll have to kick off a new image
processing and and transcoding so
transcoding is where you basically
resize it for different platforms and
stuff so we have a separate service for
that and we store those images up on
CDNs around the world and then the main
thing is to interact with the playlist
back end and update the playlists so
ideally we wouldn't have this crazy work
for we'd probably have something like
take the wrecks from HDFS and ingest
them into Cassandra but due to the
complexity of the play us back end we
want with this approach first so that's
pretty much you know that's the high
level it worked out for better for worse
and right off right right out of the
gate we start seeing some great feedback
on Twitter you know pleasantly surprised
a fair system of my taste is scary how
well discover Weekly knows me
it's nice when someone gets you stuff
like that we also had probably the most
press coverage of any release to date
for Spotify around this pretty much all
the major press outlets picked up some
kind of story around discovery weekly
and some are still coming out the other
end of it was
in September we actually had a oops and
didn't update on time and what actually
turned out to be interesting is that
users reacted to this and we could
really tell wow people are really
engaged with this playlist so we saw
stuff like it's 1041 a.m. on Monday and
I haven't seen an update yet I'm having
an existential crisis and stuff like
this threw me into a blind rage when my
playlists didn't show up so yeah so you
know we learned from this some other
things like you know we have to worry
about Sunday night updates and make sure
that our team here in New York is
capable of handling on-call stuff like
that so that's been good and now I'll
hand it back to Chris to talk about
what's next around iterating on content
quality and other things we're gonna do
with discover weekly yeah so so the last
thing is once once we've got this thing
out there it's you know what's the last
step in the last step is really to
continue to iterate so you know we've
released this this great feature but
that's not the end of the game right so
now we get to the really interesting
part where we can continue to iterate on
the quality and improve it and now we're
getting tons of feedback data so we know
what users are listening to we know what
they're skipping we know what they're
saving and we're gonna use all of that
to continue to improve upon discovery
weekly and make it even more awesome so
these ones again okay cool so basically
this is sort of the flow that we're
looking at now so one thing that's super
important with recommendation models is
getting this feedback loop in so once
you've got your recommendation model out
there it's great because now you're
gonna start getting feedback on what
users are using what they're interacting
with saves skips that sort of thing so
this is sort of what the flow looks like
we we train a bunch of collaborative
filtering models we get a bunch of
signals both track signals and user
signals how popular is a song how recent
is it you know maybe you're going to
discover that certain users only want to
see new stuff in their discovered weekly
while other users you know they want to
dip into you know old like Grateful Dead
b-sides or something right so the idea
is to take all the track signals all the
user signals and we're going to combine
them and how are we going to combine
them well we're going to use feedback
data from discover weekly in order to
combine and train those models train
hyper parameters figure out how to
weight different signals and so you end
up with this great feedback
Loup of where you're you know combining
signals you're getting some
recommendations you're putting them out
there you get new feedback you retrain
your models and so you end up in this
continual feedback loop of always kind
of improving your models and putting out
new recommendations one thing that's
super important with this is that all
this feedback data is going to come with
a presentation bias so we learned this
really quickly you know we put discover
weekly out there we start getting
feedback data and now you look at your
recommendation models and you try to
predict you know is this going to be a
skipped song or just going to be a saved
song and what you're going to notice is
that it can't distinguish between the
two so if you tried to build let's say a
under the ROC curve for this it looks
looks like you're doing terrible well
that makes sense because your
recommendation models think that all of
these songs are good on your first
iteration so one thing that becomes
super important is sampling random
negatives and this helps you sort of
step out of that presentation bias a
little bit
so to illustrate this a little bit
better this is kind of a situation I
like to think of it as this sort of
reinforcement learning view so we've got
this sort of current view of the world
right and we're going to get some
positive and negative feedback back from
that and we're gonna use that to sort of
step in the right direction and then
we're gonna get some more feedback and
we're gonna use that to step in another
direction and so it's this sort of
constant flow of stepping in another
direction of the world and we're very
slowly as we gather feedback and I try
to reach the optimal view so this is
kind of a way to think about it I think
so brings me to our last lesson are
actually there's there's one there's one
extra so lesson four is essentially this
in the end you know users know best a B
test everything it doesn't matter how
our offline metrics are performing it
doesn't matter what employees are saying
it doesn't matter what some small group
of 100 users that you're testing what
they're saying at the end of the day the
only thing that matters is your users so
at the end always a/b test everything
and that's what you're going to fit to
and then the final lesson is essentially
this and I think this is really the
story of Discover weekly discovered
weekly wasn't something that was handed
down by executives in the company it
wasn't you know we had this great grand
strategy about building these play
it was going to be amazing and we
included you know hundreds of engineers
and this it's amazing process know he
discovered weekly was you know three
engineers who were noticing some
insights and their data and the features
they were working on and then decided to
build something so I think the real
magic of discover weekly to me was that
it was a bottom it was bottom-up
innovation so I think this is super
important I think if you empower
bottom-up innovation in your
organization amazing things will happen
so this isn't to say that you shouldn't
have long term planning and you
shouldn't you shouldn't do that but I
think empowering bottom-up innovation
and trusting your engineers is super
important so that's it thank you very
much I just want to mention also we're
hiring machine learning and data
engineers so find us come chat with us
Thanks
we've got a few minutes to answer a few
questions yeah so I'll run the mic
around if you're easier in hi was a
great talk thanks my question is how
often do you have to relearn your
machine learning models and do you have
any specific strategies for like
temporary shifts in preferences
just like in news and stuff or is it
just a universal model that that's good
enough yeah so I think if I understand a
question so you're asking I think that's
two questions one is how often do we
train the models and then the second is
how do we deal with shifts in data
alright okay yeah so the models
themselves we train weekly so we'll
train our models every week which will
in turn generate new recommendations so
not only are the individual models being
trained on new data sets but the
feedback used to combine signals is
going to change every week so the
recommendations are going to be slightly
different each week which is great
because that means we're also going to
get feedback on new data points and so
it's sort of reducing that present that
presentation bias is going to get
reduced over time because we're going to
be sort of sampling from the full world
right so every week about is when the
recommendation models get trained and
then the other question you asked was
how do you deal with shifting things
like maybe you know in the news thing
you know news articles or shifting new
artists are coming in how do you deal
with that so one thing I should mention
is on the actual user data so looking at
what users are listening to we use an
exponential time decay so the stuff for
example you listen to last week is gonna
count a lot more towards your discover
weekly playlist than the stuff you
listened to three months ago and we do
the same thing with news articles and
that sort of thing articles that came
out last week count much higher than
articles that came out you know ten
weeks ago so if an artist like Drake is
really shifting his sort of music
personality we want to try to fit more
to the more recent news